it was 11 o'clock at night and young
Marriott was locked into his room
cramming as hard as he could cram he was
a fourth-year man at Edinburgh
University and he had been plowed for
this particular examination so often
that his parents had positively declared
they could no longer supply the funds to
keep him there his rooms were cheap and
dingy but it was the lecture fees that
took the money
so Marriott pulled himself together at
last and definitely made up his mind
that he would pass or die in the attempt
and for some weeks now he had been
reading as hard as mortal man can read
he was trying to make up for lost time
and money in a way that showed
conclusively he did not understand the
value of either for no ordinary man and
Marriott was in every sense an ordinary
man can afford to drive the mind as he
had lately been driving his without
sooner or later paying the cost among
the students he had few friends or
acquaintances and these few had promised
not to disturb him at night knowing he
was at last reading in earnest it was
therefore with feelings a good deal
stronger than mere surprise that he
heard his doorbell rang on this
particular night and realized that he
was to have a visitor
some men would simply have muffled the
bell and gone on quietly with their work
but Marriott was not this sort he was
nervous it would have bothered and
pecked at his mind all night long not to
know who the visitor was and what he
wanted the only thing to do therefore
was to let him in and out again as
quickly as possible the landlady went to
bed at 10 o'clock punctually after which
hour nothing would induce her to pretend
she heard the Bell so Marriott jumped up
from his books with an exclamation that
augered ill for the reception of his
caller and prepared to let him in with
his own hand
the streets of Edinburgh town were very
still at this late hour it was late for
Edinburgh and in the quiet neighborhood
of F Street where Marriott lived on the
third floor scarcely a sound broke the
silence as he crossed the floor the bell
rang a second time with unnecessary
clamor and he unlocked the door and
passed into the little hallway with
considerable wrath and annoyance in his
heart at the insolence of the double
interruption the fellows all know I'm
reading for this exam why in the world
did they come to bother me at such an
unearthly hour
the inhabitants of the building with
himself were medical students general
students poor writers to the Signet and
some others whose vocations were perhaps
not so obvious the stone staircase dimly
lighted at each floor by a gas jet that
would not turn above a certain height
wound down to the level of the street
with no pretense at carpet or railing at
some levels it was cleaner than at
others it depended on the landlady of
the particular level the acoustic
properties of a spiral staircase seemed
to be peculiar Marriott standing by the
open door book in hand thought every
moment the owner of the footsteps would
come into view the sound of the boots
was so close and so loud that they
seemed to travel disproportionately in
advance of their cause wondering who it
could be
he stood ready with all manner of sharp
greetings for the man who dared thus to
disturb his work but the man did not
appear the step sounded almost under his
nose yet no one was visible a sudden
queer sensation of fear passed over him
a faintness and a shiver down the back
it went however almost as soon as it
came and he was just debating whether he
would call aloud to his invisible
visitor or slam the door and return to
his books when the cause of the
disturbance turned the corner very
slowly and came into view it was a
stranger he saw a youngish man short a
figure and very broad his face was the
colour of a piece of chalk and the eyes
which were very bright had heavy lines
underneath them though the cheeks and
chin were unshaven and the general
appearance unkempt the man was evidently
a gentleman for he was well dressed and
bore himself with a certain air but
strangest of all he wore no hat and
carried none in his hand and all the
rain had been falling steadily all the
evening he appeared to have neither
overcoat nor umbrella a hundred
questions sprang up in Marriott's mind
and rushed to his lips chief among which
was something like who in the world are
you and what in the name of heaven do
you come to me for but none of these
questions found time to express
themselves in words for almost at once
the caller turned his head a little
so that The Gaslight in the hall fell
upon his features from a new angle then
in a flash Marriott recognized him
filled man alive is it you he gasped the
fourth year man was not lacking an
intuition and he perceived at once that
here was a case for delicate treatment
he defined without any actual process of
thought that the catastrophe often
predicted had come at last and that this
man's father had turned him out of the
house they had been at a private school
together years before and though they
had hardly met once sense the news had
not failed to reach him from time to
time with considerable detail for the
family lived near his own and between
certain of the sisters that was a great
intimacy young field had gone wild later
he remembered hearing about it all drink
a woman opium or something of the sort
he could not exactly call to mind come
in he said it once his anger vanishing
there's been something wrong I can see
come in and tell me all about it and
perhaps I can help
he hardly knew what to say and stammered
a lot more besides the dark side of life
in the horror of it belonged to a world
that lay remote from his own select
little atmosphere of books and dreamings
but he had a man's heart for all that he
led the way across the hall shutting the
front door carefully behind him and
noticed as he did so that the other
though thoroughly sober was unsteady on
his legs and evidently much exhausted
Marriott might not be able to pass his
examinations but he at least knew the
symptoms of starvation acute starvation
unless he was much mistaken when they
stared him in the face come along he
said cheerfully and with genuine
sympathy in his voice I'm glad to see
you I was going to have a bite of
something to eat and you're just in time
to join me the other made no audible
reply and shuffled so feebly with his
feet that Marriott took his arm by way
of support he noticed for the first time
that the clothes hung on him with
pitiful looseness the broad frame was
literally hardly more than a frame he
was as thin as a skeleton but as he
touched him the sensation of faintness
and dread returned it only lasted a
moment and then passed off and he
ascribed it not unnaturally to the
distress and shock of seeing a former
friend in such a pitiful plight better
let me guide you
it's shamefully dark this Hall I'm
always complaining he said lightly
recognizing by the weight upon his arm
that the guidance was sorely needed but
the old cat never does anything except
promise
he led him to the sofa wandering all the
time where he had come from and how he
had found out the address it must be at
least seven years since those days at
the private school when they used to be
such close friends now if you'll forgive
me for a minute he said I'll get supper
ready such as it is and don't bother to
talk just take it easy on the sofa I see
you're dead tired you can tell me about
it afterwards and we'll make plans the
other sat down on the edge of the sofa
and stared in silence while Marriott got
out the brown loaf scones and a huge pot
of marmalade that Edinborough students
always keep in their cupboards his eyes
shone with a brightness that suggested
drugs Marriott thought stealing a glance
at him from behind the cupboard door he
did not like yet to take a full square
look the fellow was in a bad way and it
would have been so like an examination
to stare and wait for explanations
besides he was evidently almost too
exhausted to speak so for reasons of
delicacy and for another reason as well
which he could not exactly formulate to
himself he led his visitor rest
apparently unnoticed while he busied
himself with the supper he lit the
spirit lamp to make cocoa and when the
water was boiling he drew up the table
with the good things to the sofa so that
field need not have even the trouble of
moving to a chair
now let's tuck in he said and afterwards
we'll have a pipe and a chat I'm reading
for an exam you know and I always have
something about this time it's jolly to
have a companion he looked up and caught
his guests eyes directed straight upon
his own an involuntary shudder ran
through him from head to foot the face
opposite him was deadly white and were a
dreadful expression of pain and mental
suffering by GAD he said jumping up I
quite forgot I've got some whiskey
somewhere what an ass I am
I never touch it myself when I'm working
like this he went to the cupboard and
poured out a stiff glass which the other
swallowed at a single gulp and without
any water
Marriott watched him will he drank it
and at the same time noticed something
else as well
fields coat was all over dust and on one
shoulder was a bit of a cobweb
it was perfectly dry field arrived on a
soaking wet night without hat umbrella
or overcoat and yet perfectly dry even
dusty therefore he had been under cover
what did it all mean
had he been hiding in the building it
was very strange yet he volunteered
nothing
and Marriott had pretty well made up his
mind by this time that he would not ask
any questions until he had eaten and
slept food and sleep were obviously what
the poor devil needed most and first he
was pleased with his powers of ready
diagnosis and it would not be fair to
press him until he had recovered a bit
they ate their supper together while the
host carried on a running one-sided
conversation chiefly about himself in
his exams and his old cat of a landlady
said that the guests need not utter a
single word unless he really wished to
which he evidently did not but while he
toyed with his food feeling no desire to
eat the other ate voraciously to see a
hungry man devour cold scones stale oat
cake and brown bread laden with
marmalade was a revelation to this
inexperienced student who had never
known what it was to be without at least
three meals in a day he watched in spite
of himself wondering why the fellow did
not choke in the process but field
seemed to be as sleepy as he was hungry
more than once his head dropped and he
ceased to masticate the food in his
mouth
Marriott had positively to shake him
before he could go on with his meal a
stronger emotion will overcome a weaker
but this struggle between the sting of
real hunger and the magical opiate of
overpowering sleep was a curious sight
to the student who watched it with
mingled astonishment and alarm he had
heard of the pleasure was to feed hungry
men and watch them eat but he had never
actually witnessed it and he had no idea
it was like this field ate like an
animal gobbled stuffed gorged Marriott
forgot his reading and began to feel
something very much like a lump in his
throat afraid there's been awfully
little to offer you old man he managed
to blurt out when at length alas kkona
disappeared and the rapid one-sided meal
was at an end
field still made no reply for he was
almost asleep in his seat he merely
looked up wearily and gratefully now you
must have some sleep you know he
continued or you'll go to pieces I shall
be up all night reading for this blessed
exam you're more than welcome to my bed
tomorrow we'll have a late breakfast and
and see what can be done and make plans
I'm awfully good at making plans you
know he added with an attempt at
lightness field maintained his dead
sleepy silence but appeared to acquiesce
and the other led the way into the
bedroom apologizing as he did so to this
half-starved son of a baronet whose own
home was almost a palace
for the size of the room the weary
guests however made no pretense of
thanks or politeness he merely steadied
himself on his friends arm as he
staggered across the room and then with
all his clothes on dropped his exhausted
body on the bed in less than a minute he
was to all appearances sound asleep for
several minutes Marriott stood in the
open door and watched him praying
devoutly that he might never find
himself in a like predicament and then
fell to wondering what he would do with
his unbidden guests on the morrow but he
did not stop long to think for the call
of his books was imperative and happened
what might he must see to it that he
passed that examination having again
locked the door into the hall he sat
down to his books and resumed his notes
on materia medica where he had left off
when the bell rang but it was difficult
for some time to concentrate his mind on
the subject his thoughts kept wandering
to the picture of that white face
strange eyed fellow starved and dirty
lying in his clothes and boots on the
bed he recalled their school days
together before they had drifted apart
and how they had vowed eternal
friendship and all the rest of it and
now what horrible straits to be in how
could any man let the love of
dissipation take such hold upon him but
one of their vows together Marriott it
seemed had completely forgotten just now
at any rate it lay to far in the
background of his memory to be recalled
through the half-open door the bedroom
led out of the sitting-room and had no
other door came the sound of deep
long-drawn breathing the regular steady
breathing of a tired man so tired that
even to listen to it made Marriott
almost want to go to sleep himself he
needed it reflected the student and
perhaps it came only just in time
perhaps so for outside the bitter wind
from across the fourth howled cruelly
and drove the rain and cold streams
against the windowpanes and down the
deserted streets long before Marriott
settled down again properly to his
reading he heard distantly as it were
through the sentences of the book the
heavy deep breathing of the sleeper in
the next room
a couple of hours later when a yond and
changed his books he still heard the
breathing and went cautiously up to the
door to look round at first the darkness
of the room must have deceived him or
else his eyes were confused and dazzled
by the recent glare of the reading lamp
for a minute or two he could make out
nothing at all but dark lumps of
furniture the mass of the chest of
drawers by the wall and the white patch
were his baths stood in the center of
the floor then the bed came slowly into
view and on it he saw the outline of the
sleeping body gradually takes shape
before his eyes growing up strangely
into the darkness till it stood out in
market relief the long black form
against the white counter pain he can
hardly help smiling field had not moved
an inch he watched him a moment or two
and then returned to his books the night
was full of the singing voices of the
wind and rain there was no sound of
traffic no hansoms clattered over the
cobbles and it was still too early for
the milk carts he worked on steadily and
conscientiously only stopping now and
again to change a book or to sip some of
the poisonous stuff that kept him awake
and made his brain so active and on
these occasions fields breathing was
always distinctly audible in the room
outside the storm continued to howl but
inside the house all was stillness the
shade of the reading lamp threw all the
light upon the littered table leaving
the other end of the room and
comparative darkness the bedroom door
was exactly opposite him where he sat
there was nothing to disturb the worker
nothing but an occasional rush of wind
against the windows and a slight pain in
his arm
this pain however which he was unable to
account for grew once or twice very
acute it bothered him and he tried to
remember how and when he could have
bruised himself so severely but without
success at length the page before him
turned from yellow to gray and there
were sounds of wheels in the street
below it was four o'clock Marriott lean
back and yawned prodigiously then he
drew back the curtains the storm had
subsided and the Castle Rock was
shrouded in mist with another yawn he
turned away from the tree outlook and
prepared to sleep the remaining four
hours till breakfast on the sofa field
was still breathing heavily in the next
room and he first tiptoed across the
floor to take another look at
peering cautiously around the half-open
door his first glance fell upon the bed
now plainly discernible in the gray
light of morning he stared hard then he
rubbed his eyes then he rubbed his eyes
again and thrust his head farther around
the edge of the door with fixed eyes he
stared harder still and harder but it
made no difference at all he was staring
into an empty room the sensation of fear
he had felt when field first appeared
upon the scene returned suddenly but
with much greater force he became
conscious too that his left arm was
throbbing violently and causing him
great pain he stood wandering and
staring and trying to collect his
thoughts he was trembling from head to
foot by a great effort of the well he
left the support of the door and walked
forward boldly into the room there upon
the bed was the impress of a body where
field had lain and slept there was the
mark of the head on the pillow and the
slight indentation at the foot of the
bed where the boots had rested on the
counterpane and their planar than ever
for he was closer to it was the
breathing Marriott tried to pull himself
together with a great effort he found
his voice and called his friend aloud by
name field is that you where are you
there was no reply but the breathing
continued without interruption coming
directly from the bed his voice had such
an unfamiliar sound that Marriott did
not care to repeat his questions but he
went down on his knees and examined the
bed above and below pulling the mattress
off finally and taking the coverings
away separately one by one but there the
sounds continued there was no visible
sign of field nor was there any space in
which a human being however small could
have concealed itself
he pulled the bed out from the wall but
the sound stayed where it was it did not
move with the bed Marriott finding
self-control a little difficult in his
weary condition at once said about a
thorough search of the room he went
through the cupboard the chest of
drawers the little alcove or the clothes
hung everything but there was no sign of
anyone the small window near the ceiling
was closed and anyhow it was not large
enough to let a cat pass the
sitting-room door was locked on the
inside he could not have got out that
way
curious thoughts begin to trouble
Marriott's mind bringing in their train
unwelcome some
sessions he grew more and more excited
he searched the bed again till it
resembled the scene of a pillow fight he
searched both rooms knowing all the time
it was useless and then he searched
again a cold perspiration broke out all
over his body and the sound of heavy
breathing all this time never ceased to
come from the corner where field had
lain down to sleep then he tried
something else he pushed the bed back
exactly into its original position and
himself laid out upon it just where his
guests had lain but the same instant he
sprang up again in a single bound the
breathing was close beside him on the
Stano speak and between him and the wall
not even a child could have squeezed
into the space he went back into his
sitting-room opened the windows
welcoming all the light and air possible
and tried to think the whole matter over
quietly and clearly men who read too
hard and slept too little he knew were
sometimes troubled with very vivid
hallucinations again he calmly reviewed
every incident of the night his accurate
sensations the vivid details the emotion
stirred in him the dreadful feast
no single hallucination could ever
combined all these and cover so long a
period of time but was less satisfaction
he thought of the recurring faintness
and curious sense of horror that had
once or twice come over him and then of
the violent pains in his arm these were
quite unaccountable moreover now that he
began to analyze and examine there was
one other thing that fell upon him like
a sudden revelation during the whole
time field had not actually uttered a
single word yet as though in mockery
upon his reflections there came ever
from that inner room the sound of the
breathing long draw and deep and regular
the thing was incredible it was absurd
haunted by visions of brain fever and
insanity Marriott put on his cap and
Mackintosh and left the house
the morning air on Arthur's Seat would
blow the cobwebs from his brain the
scent at the Heather and above all the
sight of the sea he roamed over the wet
slopes above Holyrood for a couple of
hours and did not return until the
exercise had shaken some of the horror
out of his bones and given him a brave
ending appetite into the bargain
as he entered he saw that there was
another man in the room standing against
the window with his back to the light he
recognized his fellow student green who
was reading for the same examination
read hard all night Marriott he said and
thought I'd drop in here to compare
notes and have some breakfast you're out
early
he added by way of a question Marriott
said he had a headache and a walk it
helped it and Green nodded and said ah
but when the girl had set the steaming
porridge on the table and gone out again
he went on with a rather forced tone
didn't know you had any friends who
drank Marriott this was obviously
tentative and Marriott replied dryly
that he did not know it either sounds
just as if some chap were sleeping it
off in there doesn't it though persisted
the other with a nod in the direction of
the bedroom and looking curiously at his
friend the two men stared steadily at
each other for several seconds and then
Marriott said earnestly than you here at
to thank God of course I hear it the
doors open sorry if I wasn't meant to oh
I don't mean that said Marriott lowering
his voice but I'm awfully relieved let
me explain of course if you hear it too
then it's alright but really it
frightened me more than I can tell you I
thought I was going to have brain fever
or something and you know what a lot
depends on this exam it always begins
with sounds or visions or some sort of
beastly hallucination and I rot
ejaculated the other impatiently what
are you talking about now listen to me
Green said Marriott as calmly as he
could for the breathing was still
plainly audible and I'll tell you what I
mean only don't interrupt and thereupon
he related exactly what had happened
during the night telling everything even
down to the pain in his arm when it was
over he got up from the table and
crossed the room you hear the breathing
now plainly don't you he said Green said
he did well come with me and we'll
search the room together the other
however did not move from his chair I've
been in already
he said sheepishly I heard the sounds
and thought it was you the door was ajar
so I went in Marriott made no comment
but push the door open as wide as it
would go as it opened the sound of
breathing grew more and more distinct
someone must be in there
said Green under his breath
someone is in there but we're said
Marriott again he urged his friend to go
in with him but Greene refused
point-blank said he had been in once and
it searched the room and there was
nothing there he would not go in again
for a good deal they shut the door and
retired into the other room to talk it
all over with many pipes Green
questioned his friend very closely but
without illuminating result since
questions cannot alter facts the only
thing that ought to have a proper a
logical explanation is the pain in my
arm said Marriott rubbing that member
with an attempt at a smile
it hurts so infernally and aches all the
way up I can't remember bruising it
though let me examine it for you said
Greene
I'm awfully good at bones in spite of
the examiner's opinion to the contrary
it was a relief to play the fool a bit
and Marriott took his coat off and
rolled up his sleeve by George though
I'm bleeding he exclaimed look here what
on earth sis on the forearm quite close
to the wrist was a thin red line there
was a tiny drop of apparently fresh
blood on it Green came over and looked
closely at it for some minutes then he
sat back in his chair looking curiously
at his friend's face you scratched
yourself without knowing it he said
presently
there's no sign of a bruise it must be
something else that made the arm ache
Marriott sat very still staring silently
at his arm as though the solution of the
whole mystery lay there actually written
upon the skin what's the matter
I see nothing very strange about a
scratch said Greene and an unconvincing
sort of voice it was your cufflinks
probably last night in your excitement
but Marriott white to the very lips was
trying to speak the sweat stood in great
beads on his forehead
at last he leaned forward close to his
friends face look he said in a low voice
that shook a little do you see that red
mark I mean underneath what you call the
scratch Greene admitted he saw something
or other and Marriott wiped the place
clean with his handkerchief and told him
to look again more closely yes I see
returned the other lifting his head
after a moment's careful inspection it
looks like an old scar it is an old scar
whispered Marriott his lips trembling
now it all comes back to me all what
green fidgeted on his chair he tried to
laugh but with
success his friends seemed bordering on
collapse
hush be quiet and I'll tell you he said
field made that scar for a whole minute
the two men looked each other full in
the face without speaking field made
that scar repeated Marriott at length in
a louder voice field you mean last night
no not last night years ago at school
with his knife and I made a scar and his
arm with mine Marriott was talking
rapidly now we exchanged drops of blood
in each other's cuts he put a drop into
my arm and I put one into his in the
name of heaven what for it was a boy's
compact we made a secret pledge a
bargain I remember it all perfectly now
we had been reading some dreadful book
and we swore to appear to one another I
mean whoever died first swore to show
himself to the other and we sealed the
compact with each other's blood I
remember it all so well the hot summer
afternoon in the playground seven years
ago and one of the Masters caught us and
confiscated the knives and I've never
thought of it again to this day and you
mean stammered green but Marriott made
no answer he got up and crossed the room
and lay down wearily upon the sofa
hiding his face in his hands Greene
himself was a bit nonplussed
he left his friend alone for a little
while thinking it all over again
suddenly an idea seemed to strike him he
went over to where Marriott still lay
motionless on the sofa and roused him in
any case it was better to face the
matter whether there was an explanation
or not giving in was always the silly
exit I say Marriott he began as the
other turned his white face up to him
there's no good being so upset about it
I mean if it's all a hallucination we
know what to do and if it isn't well we
know what to think don't we I suppose so
but it frightens me horribly for some
reason returned his friend in a hushed
voice and that poor devil but after all
if the worst is true and and that chap
has kept his promise well he has that's
all isn't it Marriott nodded there's
only one thing that occurs to me Greene
went on and that is are you quite sure
that that he really ate like that I mean
that he actually ate anything at all he
finished blurting out all his thought
Marriot stared at him for a moment and
then said he could easily make certain
he spoke quietly after the main shock no
lesser surprise could affect him
I put the things away myself he said
after we had finished there on the third
shelf in that cupboard no one's touched
them since he pointed without getting up
and Greene took the hint and went over
to look exactly he said after a brief
examination just as I thought it was
partly hallucination at any rate the
things haven't been touched come and see
for yourself together they examined the
Shelf there was the brown loaf the plate
of stale scones the oat cake all
untouched even the glass of whiskey
Marriott had poured out stood there with
the whiskey still in it you were feeding
no one said green field ate and drank
nothing he was not there at all but the
breathing urged the other in a low voice
staring with a dazed expression on his
face Greene did not answer he walked
over to the bed room while Marriott
followed him with his eyes he opened the
door and listened there was no need for
words the sound of deep regular
breathing came floating through the air
there was no hallucination about that at
any rate Marriott could hear it where he
stood on the other side of the room
Greene closed the door and came back
there's only one thing to do
he declared with decision right home and
find out about him and meanwhile come
and finish your reading in my rooms I've
got an extra bed agreed returned the
fourth year man there's no hallucination
about that exam I must pass that
whatever happens and this was what they
did
it was about a week later when Marriott
got the answer from his sister part of
it he read out to green it is curious
she wrote that in your letter you should
have inquired after field it seems a
terrible thing but you know only a short
while ago Sir John's patience became
exhausted and he turned him out of the
house they say without a penny well what
do you think he has killed himself at
least it looks like suicide instead of
leaving the house he went down into the
cellar and simply starved himself to
death they're trying to suppress it of
course but I heard it all from my maid
who got it from their footman they found
the body on the 14th and the doctor said
he had died about 12 hours before he was
dreadfully thin then he died on the 13th
said Greene Marriott nodded that's the
very night he came to see you Marriott
nodded again
a volley of illumination blue red blue
red assaulted Ben's closed eyelids as he
woke he groaned and turned over in his
bed only to be met with a more intense
pulse from the other side he opened his
eyes the entire ceiling was a carnival
of gaily rotating lights crashing in
through the rims one small window he sat
up police cars the floor was cold
against his bare feet as he padded to
the window he couldn't see the cars from
here but the lights were near blinding
pulling on a pair of jeans he crossed
the room and went out into the hall the
house was deathly quiet the particular
sort of silence reserved for the night
before the first early morning of a new
academic year it seemed that not
everyone was taking advantage of the
final summer sleep though the door of
the room next to his was wide open and
Ben glanced inside as he passed what he
saw was so odd that he stopped a young
man clad only in drooping boxer shorts
stood with his back to the door before
him was a large flat-screen television
on which the unmoving image of a smiling
red-haired woman loomed at twice
life-size the young man's stance was
wide his feet planted firmly on the
floor his hands were clenched into fists
by his side's he stared at the picture
on the screen and Ben could almost feel
the rage emanating from the man in
sickening waves
you filthy [ __ ] the man suddenly
screamed and Ben nearly leapt out of his
skin you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you come
dumpster then hurried away from the door
his hurt something in rapid time with
the blue and red lights that still
throbbed across the walls he didn't
think the crazy guy had seen him and he
wasn't going to call out to him to ask
what the hell that had been all about
downstairs the kitchen and living area
were deserted the flashers from outside
made the ground floor look like the
inside of a fish tank Ben went to the
front window and parted the blinds with
his fingers there were two police cars
parked on the curb facing one another he
couldn't see anyone around the cars and
couldn't make out any silhouettes inside
in fact the entire street comprised of
nothing but late 1920s frame houses
converted into student apartments was
completely desolate
frowning been turned from the window and
was promptly startled by the figure of a
woman leaning against the kitchen
counter he hadn't heard anyone come in
her features were mostly shadowed but in
the glow from the flashers he could make
out the lengths of straight dark hair
that curtains her thin face
I wonder what's going on out there Ben
said trying to hide the quaver in his
voice the girl shrugged then turned her
back to him and fiddled with something
on the counter it took Ben a moment to
see that she was dipping a tea bag into
a mug was studied almost robotic motions
he felt he ought to say something else
but before he could she grabbed her
teacup and wandered off toward the
stairs melting into the shadows as if
she had never been there
unsettled Ben glanced out the window
again but the scene hadn't changed he
really ought to be getting back to bed
his first class of the semester began at
8:00 and his punctuality was something
of a point of pride but he wasn't sure
he would be able to sleep every nerve in
his body was tuned and vibrating against
the heavy air he wasn't even sure what
time it was
at last he accepted his wakefulness and
rounded the bar into the kitchen
snagging a soda from the communal
refrigerator he could stay down here for
a while at least until he got tired he
could keep an eye on things he popped
open the can and took a long swig while
standing by the sink and looking out the
windows on either side of the front door
the light still flashed and the house
remained indifferent around him suddenly
the doorknob turned he hadn't seen or
heard anyone approaching the house he
would have thought the door was locked
at night but it opened freely and in
tumbled a tall blond man with his well
muscled arms and circling a giggling
young woman in jeans and a black blouse
her ponytail swished as the pair
collapsed onto the rug and began kissing
exuberantly not even bothering to close
the door behind them they didn't seem to
notice been standing there or if they
did they paid him no attention Ben felt
uncomfortable watching them but he was
afraid to move for fear they would see
him he backed discreetly into the
shadows hoping they would be finished
with their business sooner rather than
later
the pair seemed in no hurry the woman
kneeling on the carpet with her back to
been pulled her shirt off over her head
and tossed it aside the strap of the
black bra beneath made a harsh line
across her flesh Ben wanted to sink into
the floor
the man crouched over her a lascivious
grin parting his wide face
she laughed but then gasped as he
grabbed her by the ankles hard and
yanked her legs up and apart Ben
couldn't see her face but he could sense
the shift in the atmosphere and he
thought he hurt her murmuring for him to
stop the man did not stop even from his
vantage point Ben could see the man's
powerful hands closing tighter and
tighter around her ankles and for one
absurd moment Ben thought to himself
that he was surely going to pull the
poor woman's feet off it occurred to him
that he should call out or try to stop
him somehow but he was frozen in place
staring at the surreal scene and
horrified shock and then unbelievably
the woman's feet indeed separated from
her ankles there was no sound and no
blood that he could see the girl didn't
even scream but Ben clearly heard the
sickening thump as the feet hit the
carpet and just lay there incongruous
and cleanly removed like latex Halloween
props the soda-can was clutched so hard
in Ben's hand that the aluminum was
buckling but he barely noticed he was
still standing there in complete
disbelief when the man's head jerked up
huge ice blue eyes stared right into his
and Ben felt his bladder let go the man
leaped to his feet leaving the girl to
slump over into a parent unconsciousness
he approached the bar behind which Ben
stood and his arm shot out with
impossible speed his hand closing around
Ben's wrist Ben stared stupidly down at
the man's manacled grip and then the man
began to pull been kicked out blindly
though he was sure the kicks didn't
connect because of the bar separating
them the tendons in his forearm were
beginning to creak in a moment of panic
he slammed the half empty can against
the man's arm but of course it crumpled
uselessly had dropped to the ground Ben
tried to yell but his throat was closed
so tightly that barely any air escaped
and then he began to thrash his body
back and forth as violently as he could
the man's face dominated his entire
field of view those eyes boring into his
that high forehead with the swept back
hair that wide toothy rictus of a grin
been had ample time for the contours of
that face to burn themselves into his
memory and then he awoke thrashing and
sweaty in his own bed in his own room
upstairs it was still full dark outside
the window and no police lights danced
across the ceiling the house was as
silent as a tomb then pulled the covers
up to his chin and lay completely still
until the Sun came up after downing two
cans of Red Bull Ben was just able to
gather his things together and step out
into the crisp September morning his
eyes were so dry that it hurt to blink
the campus was swarmed with people most
of them looking painfully young and lost
as Ben suppose he did he jostled his way
through the throngs and the noise
keeping his head down not meeting
anyone's gaze he had nearly reached his
destination when a piece of paper was
thrust beneath his nose sign the
petition
a girls voice screeched in his ear just
as for Janis Ben cringed and looked up
the girl who had spoken was a stranger
to him an elfin creature with large
black eyes that blinked intensely at him
from behind square glasses she was
holding a sign made from pink poster
board that read justice for Janis and
thick black marker there was an
eight-by-ten photo pasted beneath the
phrase and Ben stopped dead when he saw
it the woman in the picture was
red-haired and smiling she was also the
same woman who had appeared in his dream
on the television screen in the room
next door to his who Ben began but a
laughing group of students heaved beside
him and their boisterous movement
carried him past the girl with the
petition when he glanced back over his
shoulder only the corner of the sign was
still visible and the bespectacled girl
had turned away from him he rounded his
shoulders and pushed his way toward the
doors of the English department his
first class was on the second floor and
he made his way quickly up the stairs
feeling the caffeine throbbing
unpleasantly through his bloodstream the
classroom was half full as he entered it
and no one turned to look as he slipped
through the door and took a seat near
the back of the room
for that he was grateful he pulled out
his phone and began pouring through the
online syllabus again committing it to
memory another group of students piled
in moments later and been barely
registered their entry there was a
thumping noise nearby and he briefly
glanced from his phone to see the bottom
of a crutch and next to that a foot in a
bright white cast he looked up and saw a
girl dressed in a black blouse and jeans
placing her purse on the desk directly
in front of his a ponytail snaked down
her back Ben clutched the sides of his
phone so hard as knuckles went white he
hadn't seen the girl's face but the
clothes and hair were the same the way
she moved was the same he had a brief
flash of her slumping onto the carpet in
the front room of his apartment building
of her cleanly severed feet his eyes
roved helplessly down to the cast on her
right foot he was still dreaming that
was the only explanation for a moment he
considered tapping the girl on the
shoulder to tell her something but just
then the professor strode into the room
and everyone felt quiet Ben couldn't
tear his gaze from the girl he felt sick
and unreal and as the professor began
talking he had to fight back the urge to
vomit he didn't hear a single word the
man said it seemed only minutes had
passed before the class was over and
there was a general shuffling as
everyone gathered their things the girl
slid out of her seat balancing on her
good leg while draping her purse over
one arm Ben felt a stab of panic
wondering whether he should say anything
to her and then wondering what exactly
he could say without sounding completely
insane she was preparing to leave and he
thought he had decided to let it go but
then he heard his own voice seemingly
coming from a long way away do you need
any help with your stuff the girl turned
toward him and even though he knew she
was the same girl as his dream he was
still surprised to see her familiar face
she considered him somewhat coolly
but without malice I'm all right thanks
what happened he was shocked that he had
spoken again it wasn't in his nature at
all she sighed almost imperceptibly
annoyed but trying not to show it just a
dumb accident SIA
been stood quickly almost knocking his
desk over he thought he saw a scowl curl
the corner of the girl's mouth wait a
second I know this might sound weird but
I really have to go
she said savagely cramming the padded
end of the crutch into her armpit and
maneuvering into the aisle I think you
might be in danger
Ben called but she was already something
away pointedly not looking back at him
obviously wishing she could move faster
Ben considered following but thought
better of it she wouldn't believe him if
he told her he would just be some nerdy
creep trailing after her with the
world's most bizarre pickup line he
collapsed back into his chair rubbing
his exhausted eyes with his hands the
rest of his classes passed in a haze Ben
heard nothing retained nothing and
simply took up space to no effect he
didn't see the girl in the cast again
after his final class of the day he
dragged himself out into the afternoon
the sky had gone ominously gray and the
crowds had significantly finned
he saw the woman with the sign again and
now there were others with her all
holding variations at the same sign with
the same photo of the red-haired girl a
small knot of people had gathered around
them and the woman in the glasses was
speaking and emitted Lee but Ben
couldn't hear what she was saying the
front room of his apartment building was
empty he carried his things up the
stairs to his room he had never felt so
tired in his entire life and his stomach
was rumbling painfully all he wanted was
a sandwich and a long dreamless sleep
he reached the door of his room and
placed his hand on the knob the door
beside his opened and a young man popped
his head out hey my TV didn't keep you
up last night did it sorry I fell asleep
with it on been slowly registered the
man smiling face he was wearing a red
t-shirt and jeans and been idly wondered
if he was wearing those drooping boxer
shorts underneath them no I didn't hear
anything oh good I'll try not to do it
again seriously I'm Jake by the way Ben
cool well I'll let you go I've got some
[ __ ] to do you look [ __ ] beat yeah
first day and all
Ben could barely get the words out his
thoughts filled with Jake's voice you
filthy [ __ ] you [ __ ] he hurried into
his room and closed the door turning the
lock
he tossed his bag onto his desk and sat
down on the edge of the bed he was
tempted to simply lie back and sleep
food be damned but he hadn't eaten in
more than 24 hours and was beginning to
feel dizzy he heaved himself to his feet
and made his way downstairs he heard
laughter before he rounded the corner to
the front room and sighed inwardly he'd
been hoping to simply get some food and
scurry back to his room without having
to have any uncomfortable interaction
with anyone especially in the state of
mind he was in the girl was sitting on
the couch and her back was to him he
couldn't be sure but he thought it was
the same woman who had been standing in
the kitchen in his dream the one who had
made tea and brushed him off when he
came downstairs to investigate the
police lights it was her laughter he had
heard there was a young man with her
facing toward the kitchen has been
entered for what seemed like the
hundredth time that day been stopped
short and stared it was the man the one
who had torn off the girl's feet he
looked slightly less sinister in person
but not by much his hair was swept back
and his forehead glared a little in the
afternoon light from the front windows
his eyes were large and blue cold he
didn't seem to have noticed been he was
listening to something the girl was
saying and laughing along with her been
considered simply turning around and
going back up to his room but then the
man's gaze shifted and their eyes met
the man didn't appear to recognize been
at all but he did look at him oddly as
if wondering what he was doing there his
huge forehead crinkled been managed to
smile and continued into the kitchen
giving his hand a slight wave for good
measure the man's attention waned and he
continued talking to the girl there they
were whispering and Ben couldn't really
hear what they were saying he slapped a
sandwich together as quickly as he could
not even putting any condiments on it
just lapping some lunch meat on plain
white bread and grabbing a paper towel
to wrap it in before retreating to the
stairs the girl should probably be
warned he thought but why should she
listen the girl with the cast certainly
hadn't and all this had probably just
been a strange dream anyway even though
Ben knew and his bones that something
else was going on that the dream had
been trying to tell him something the
man in the front room was dangerous he
had seen it there had to be a way to
warn people about him without sounding
like an idiot but as exhausted as he
felt he couldn't think of it just now
he went back to his room and locked the
door he crammed the dry sandwich into
his mouth without tasting it and lay
back against the pillow without even
brushing off the crumbs he was asleep in
seconds it was ful dark when he awoke
two lights and noise that blue red blue
red pulsing from his dream and the sound
of many raised voices his stomach
clenched to think that the dream had
returned but this time he was sure he
was awake and he pinched himself on the
inside of his forearm to confirm wincing
he rolled out of bed there were cop cars
outside flashing their lights against
his walls
the clock on his bedside table read
10:28 he opened the door a crack and
peered out into the hallway
only to be confronted with a swarming
throb of activity uniformed officers
three or four of them mingled with a few
people and campus police shirts and a
bundle of female students in yoga pants
and tank tops who were craning their
necks trying to see in through the door
of his immediate neighbor Kyle had that
been his name John no Jake one of the
campus officers noticed been peeking out
and gestured to him with a curling
finger Ben stepped out into the hall
still hanging on to the doorknob have
you been in your room all evening
the officer snapped Ben goggled at him
yeah I was sleeping did you hear
anything strange a fight or a struggle
no I was tired I fell asleep earlier
this afternoon and slept straight
through what happened one of the real
police officers stepped forward then and
looked been up and down taking in his
weedy frame and fishie pale flesh did
you see anyone go into this room at any
point
no just the guy who lives there Jake
right I saw him this afternoon Ben
described the circumstances while the
officer stared at him is that we'd like
to gobble him up and there was no one
else in the room with him at that time
Ben could barely meet the officers
accusing gaze I guess there could have
been he only just leaned out the door
and then went back in I didn't see or
hear anyone else though stick around all
of you the officer said pointing around
the hall to encompass all the students
in the immediate vicinity we're probably
going to need to ask more questions when
we get this sorted out
but what happened the officer turned
away has been asked so he transferred
his questioning look to the girl closest
to him she happened to be the same girl
from the dream kitchen the one who'd
been talking to the foot Ripper this
afternoon on the couch the blond
psychopath was nowhere to be seen
however he's dead what do you think
happened the girl replied she was trying
to sound [ __ ] and flippant but her
eyes were terrified and her voice
squeaked he's all torn up like in pieces
blood everywhere how Ben began but
whatever words he was going to say next
dried up in his throat as three EMTs
emerged from the room next door pushing
a stretcher bearing a zipped black body
bag with a disturbingly lumpy contour
the copper tang of blood wafted out in a
cloud behind it then caught himself
craning his neck to try to see into the
apartment then pulled himself back why
in the hell would he want to see that
the police officers were still there
some of them disappearing into Jake's
room and some of the others remaining in
the hallway talking to the other
students been watched kitchen girl as
she headed toward the stairs only to be
intercepted by one of the officers as
soon as her back was turned toward him
Ben gestured to one of the other cops
not believing what he was about to do
not having any idea of what he was going
to say but feeling the burning need to
say something there was someone I didn't
really recognize down in the lobby
earlier Ben said when he got the
officers attention he kept his voice low
so that kitchen girl would not hear him
I mean I don't think he lives here and I
thought he looked kind of he floundered
for a moment trying to find the words
that would convey the sense of Menace
the man had given off in the dream
sinister I guess he finished when was
this
could you describe him Ben recounted the
man's appearance as well as he was able
carefully leaving kitchen girl out of
the description a part of his mind was
screaming at him that he was being crazy
that this man had never done anything
that would warrant an accusation of
murder but Ben quieted his doubts if the
man hadn't done anything then the police
would eventually figure that out and if
the man had done something then Ben
would have perhaps saved someone else
from The Killers wrath besides he wasn't
coming right out and saying the guy had
killed Jake
he was just describing a stranger who
had been in the house he was simply
being a responsible citizen
the officer wrote down everything been
said then thanked him for his time and
moved on to someone else the residents
of the house that had already been
questioned were still gathered in a knot
around the staircase waiting to be
dismissed they were all young women and
all were wide-eyed with terror as they
spoke to each other in hushed tones then
considered going over to talk to them
but thought better of it and instead
leaned against the stair railing with
his arms crossed trying to look casual
and blameless then a word emerged from
the woman's muted conversation that made
Ben's ears prick up Janice he knew he
had recently seen her heard that name
somewhere but at the moment he couldn't
put his finger on the circumstances then
he had it anxiously he approached the
women they all immediately stop talking
and stared at him as though he was a fox
that had come barreling into a henhouse
who's Janice he asked it seemed clear
that none of the women wanted to answer
him and there were several seconds of
awkward silence at last a mousy brown
haired girl tilted her head at him who
are you she asked Ben I live here the
girl curled her lips at him as if
considering whether this was an
acceptable answer or not
evidently she decided it was because she
said I don't know much about her it
happened a long time ago I heard about
it for my brother one of the other women
said he graduated back in 2006 it was
big news back then what happened Ben
asked girl named Janice she was a
student here lived in one of these
apartment houses may have been this one
even I don't really know she was raped
and murdered by two guys other students
did the guys get away or something
I saw people with signs this morning
then helplessly pictured the sinister
blond man again wondering if this had
been what the dream was trying to tell
him the original brown-haired girl piped
up again they were caught and convicted
believe it or not they both died in
prison though pretty recently I don't
really remember how I guess that's why
people are bringing it up again because
the boy's parents are wigging out
wanting their names cleared saying they
were innocent and got locked up for
nothing and now they're dead bla bla she
waved a dismissive hand sounds to me
like they did it though so [ __ ] those
guys the other women nodded and
thoughtful agreement and Ben withdrew
from them in the face of their callous
indifference
they continue talking amongst themselves
after he left as though he had never
been there shortly afterward the police
concluded their business and trundled
out of the house in one body
leaving only a garish slash of
crime-scene tape in their wake
there was a hub of outside as they ran
the gauntlet of the collected media
representatives but even this sound was
cut off when the front door of the house
was slammed shut
been watched as the students dispersed
back to their rooms many of them to pack
their things to stay elsewhere been
having nowhere else to go simply went
into his room and locked the door behind
him the house was deathly quiet as night
fell outside the windows and Ben began
to question his decision to stay in the
house it seemed no one else had he was
surprised the police had let anyone stay
as he turned on the lamps to stave off
the darkness he couldn't stop thinking
about the carnage that had taken place
just on the other side of his bedroom
wall nervously he peered out the window
not mollified in the least by the sight
of the empty back parking lot and a
series of burned-out streetlights after
several minutes of aimless pacing he
decided he might as well go downstairs
maybe some media people were still
outside the sight and sound of other
people even News vultures would be
comforting
he opened his door slowly looking both
ways up and down the hall before
stepping out the yellow crime-scene tape
across Jake's door was the only burst of
color in the otherwise vast expanse of
gray and black the downstairs was in
darkness also but Ben was relieved to
see that there were indeed lights and
voices coming from outside he looked
through the closed blinds and saw
several news vans parked on the curb and
various people milling around holding
microphones and lighting equipment he
nodded to himself and turned back toward
the kitchen
there was a girl silhouetted there
standing behind the bar Ben stopped he
was sure she hadn't been there when he
had come downstairs maybe a few of the
residents had stayed in the house after
all I didn't think anyone was here Ben
said and his voice sounded hollow in the
empty space the girl didn't answer he
couldn't see her face at all though he
could tell her hair was long he thought
of his dream and wondered if this was
the same girl from before the one who
had made tea and ignored him
the one that it later been consorting
with the sinister blonde man on the sofa
was he about to see his dream play out
in real life now his stomach clenched I
stayed the girl said and been nearly
jumped out of his skin
her voice was soft and belt like with
none of the sardonic edge that had
categorized the voice of the kitchen
girl I'm glad Ben said because her
statement seemed to deserve an answer I
thought I was in here all alone it isn't
good to be alone
she said she shifted her position a
little silently and Ben thought he could
see a glint of red across her ample
tresses terrible things can happen yeah
I guess they can he still had not
approached her and now his heart was
beginning to hammer was the blond man
about to come bursting through the front
door to tear her limb from limb but that
was stupid there were people all over
the place outside someone would see him
then another thought came to him what if
the man had snuck in with all the police
officers what if he was hiding somewhere
in the house right now
look what happened to poor Jake the girl
lowered her head slightly and Ben could
have sworn he heard her chuckle he
dismissed the idea almost the moment he
had thought it that was pretty horrible
alright Ben strained to see her in the
darkness but he still couldn't make out
her features he gave up and began
scanning the shadows around the room
wondering if someone else was watching
them he wished more than anything else
that he'd turned the lights on when he
first come downstairs are you the only
one left in here except for you the girl
said and Ben could practically hear the
predatory smile in her voice his body
temperature dropped several degrees he
had the sudden urge to sprint out the
front door into the waiting arms of the
straggling police in media but for some
reason he was frozen to the spot just as
he'd been in his dream why did you stay
Ben asked the girl somehow seemed to
have gotten closer to him though she
hadn't actually moved I can't leave why
did you stay nowhere else to go his
throat was dry everything was suddenly
very quiet as though they were the only
two people left on earth
that's too bad the girl said she tilted
her head and been caught that glimmer of
red Harrigan on some level he knew who
she was but he couldn't wrap his head
around it around how she could be here
do you know what those two boys called
me it was on the tip of his tongue to
ask what boy she was talking about but
he knew he knew what she was going to
say he knew and he was powerless to stop
it
filthy [ __ ] they said her voice was mild
as though she was discussing the weather
[ __ ] [ __ ]
lots of other things they didn't even
know me I had never done anything to
them why do you suppose they did that I
don't know Janice they were terrible
people they're dead now
they paid for what they did did they
the girls stepped out from behind the
bar her hair hung straight on either
side of her face like curtains of blood
framing a perfect visages vengeance it
wasn't enough they didn't suffer enough
none of you have then began to back
toward the door but somehow he couldn't
find it it didn't seem as though it was
where it was supposed to be everything
had taken on that surrealist aspect
again and he began to pray fervently and
silently that this was a dream again
that it had all been a dream everything
that had happened from the moment he had
arrived at this house Janice
he said his palms extended toward her in
his head played a continuous loop of I
can't believe I'm talking to a dead girl
you all have to pay eventually she said
with a strangely casual shrug you just
happen to be the only other man here
right now so you'll have to do the last
thing been remembered was Janice's face
growing larger and larger in his vision
the way he had first seen her on the TV
screen in Jake's room
she was smiling and she looked almost
angelic then he felt cold
ironheart fingers close around his
ankles and then there was a tearing
wrenching sensation that began at his
feet and continued upward until he was
pierced by something huge that seemed to
expand inside his abdomen he had a
moment of clarity where he managed a
choked gurgling scream and then it
cleaved him into
[Music]
two men in a smoking room were talking
of their private school days and our
school said eh we had a ghost foot mark
on the staircase what was it like oh
very unconvincing just the shape of a
shoe with a square toe if I remember
right the staircase was a stone one I
never heard any story about the thing
that seemed odd when you come to think
of it why didn't somebody invent one I
wonder you never can tell with little
boys they have a mythology of their own
there's a subject for you by the way the
folklore of private schools yes the crop
is rather scanty though I imagine if you
were to investigate the cycle of ghost
stories for instance which the boys at
private schools tell each other they
would all turn out to be highly
compressed versions of stories out of
books nowadays The Strand and Pearson's
and so on would be extensively drawn
upon no doubt they weren't born or
thought of in my time let's see I wonder
if I can remember the staple ones that I
was told first there was the house with
a room in which a series of people
insisted on passing a night and each of
them in the morning was found kneeling
in a corner and had just time to say
I've seen it and died wasn't that the
house in Berkeley Square I dare say it
was then there was the man who heard a
noise in the passage at night opened his
door and saw someone crawling towards
him on all fours with his eye hanging
out on his cheek there was besides let
me think yes the room where a man was
found dead in bed with a horseshoe mark
on his forehead and the floor under the
bed was covered with marks of horseshoes
also I don't know why also there was the
lady who unlocking her bedroom door in a
strange house heard a thin voice among
the bed curtains say now were shut in
for the night none of those had any
explanation or sequel I wonder if they
go on still those stories Oh likely
enough with additions from the magazines
as I said you never heard did you have a
real ghost at a private school I thought
not nobody has that I ever came across
from the way in which you said that I
gather that you have
I really don't know but this is what was
in my mind it happened at my private
school 30 odd years ago and I haven't
any explanation of it the school I mean
was near London it was established in a
large and fairly old house a great white
building with very fine grounds about it
there were large Cedars in the garden as
there are and so many of the older
gardens in the Thames Valley and ancient
Elms and the three or four fields which
we used for our games I think probably
it was quite an attractive place but
boys sell them allow that their schools
possess any tolerable features I came to
the school in a September soon after the
year 1870 and among the boys who arrived
on the same day was one whom I took to a
Highland boy whom I will call him a
cloud I needed to spend time in
describing him the main thing is that I
got to know him very well he was not an
exceptional boy in any way not
particularly good at books or games but
he suited me the school was a large one
there must have been from 120 to 130
boys there as a rule and so a
considerable staff of masters was
required and there were rather frequent
changes among them one term perhaps it
was my third or fourth a new master made
his appearance his name was Samson he
was a tallish stoutish pale
black-bearded man I think we liked him
he had travelled a good deal and had
stories which amused us on our school
walks so that there was some competition
among us to get within earshot of him I
remember - dear me I've hardly thought
of it since then that he had a charm on
his watch-chain
that attracted my attention one day and
he let me examine it it was I now
suppose a gold Byzantine coin there was
an effigy of some absurd Emperor on one
side the other side had been worn
practically smooth and he had had cut on
it rather barbarously his own initials
GWS and a date 24 July 1865 yes I can
see it now he told me he had picked it
up in Constantinople it was about the
size of a Florin perhaps rather smaller
well the first odd thing that happened
was this Samson was doing Latin grammar
with us one of his favorite methods
perhaps it is a rather good one was to
make us construct sentences out of our
own heads to illustrate the rules he was
trying to make us learn
of course that is a thing which gives a
silly boy a chance of being impertinent
there are lots of school stories in
which that happens or anyhow there might
be but Samson was too good at
disciplinarian for us to think of trying
that on with him now in this occasion he
was telling us how to express
remembering in Latin and he ordered us
to each make a sentence bringing in the
verb mem aney I remember well most of us
made up some ordinary sentence such as I
remember my father or he remembers his
book or something equally uninteresting
and I dare say a good many put-down
mommy no Libra Mayim and so forth but
the boy I mentioned McLeod was evidently
thinking of something more elaborate
than that the rest of us wanted to have
our sentences past and get on to
something else
so some kicked him under the desk and I
who was next to him poked him and
whispered to him to look sharp but he
didn't seem to attend I looked at his
paper and saw that he had put down
nothing at all
so I jogged him again harder than before
and abraded him sharply for keeping us
all waiting that did have some effect
he started and seemed to wake up and
then very quickly he scribbled about a
couple of lines on his paper and showed
it up with the rest as it was the last
or nearly the last to come in and as
Sampson had a good deal to say to the
boys who had written them in isthmus
patrie Mayo and the rest of it it turned
out that the clock struck 12:00 before
he had got some a cloud and the cloud
had to wait afterwards to have his
sentence corrected there was nothing
much going on outside when I got out so
I waited for him to come he came very
slowly when he did arrive and I guess
there had been some sort of trouble well
I said what did you get oh I don't know
said McLeod nothing much but I think
Samson's rather sick with me why did you
show him up Samrat no fear he said it
was alright as far as I could see it was
like this memento that's right enough
for remember and it takes a genitive
memento bootay inter quater attack Soze
what's silly rot I said what made you
shove that down what does it mean that's
the funny part said McLeod I'm not quite
sure what it does mean all I know is it
just came into my head and I corked it
down I know what I think it means
because just before I wrote it down I
had a sort of picture of it in my head
I believe it means remember the well
among the four what are those dark sort
of trees that have the red berries on
them Mountain ashes I suppose you mean I
never heard of them said MacLeod
no I'll tell you use well and what did
Sampson say why he was jolly odd about
it when he read it he got up and went to
the mantelpiece and stopped quite a long
time without saying anything with his
back to me and then he said without
turning round and rather quiet what do
you suppose that means
I told him what I thought only I
couldn't remember the name of the silly
tree and then he wanted to know why I
put it down and I had to say something
or other and after that he left off
talking about it and asked me how long
I'd been here and where my people lived
and things like that and then I came
away but he wasn't looking a bit well I
don't remember anymore that was said by
either of us about this next day MacLeod
took to his bed with a chill or
something of the kind and it was a week
or more before he was in school again
and as much as a month went by without
anything happening that was noticeable
whether or not mr. Sampson was really
startled asthma clouded thought he
didn't show it I'm pretty sure of course
now that there was something very
curious in his past history but I'm not
going to pretend that we boys were sharp
enough to guess any such thing there was
one other incident of the same kind as
the last which I told you several times
since that day we had had to make up
examples in school to illustrate
different rules but there had never been
any Rauh except when we did them wrong
at last there came a day when we were
going through this dismal things which
people call conditional sentences and we
were told to make a conditional sentence
expressing a future consequence we did
it right or wrong and showed up our bits
of paper and Sampson began looking
through them all at once he got up made
some odd sort of noise in his throat and
rushed out by a door that was just by
his desk we sat there for a minute or
two and then I suppose it was incorrect
but we went up I and one or two of the
others and looked at the papers on his
desk of course I thought someone must
have put down some nonsense or other and
Sampson had gone off to report him all
the same I noticed that he hadn't taken
any of the papers with him when he ran
out
well the top paper on the desk was
written in red ink which no one used and
it wasn't in anyone's hand who was in
the class they all looked at it MacLeod
and all and took their dying oaths that
it wasn't theirs then I thought of
counting the bits of paper and of this I
made quite certain that there were
seventeen bits of paper on the desk and
sixteen boys in the form
well I bagged the extra paper and kept
it and I believe I have it now and now
you will want to know what was written
on it
it was simple enough and harmless enough
I should have said si tu non veneris ad
may a Govi neum a da which means I
suppose if you don't come to me I'll
come to you could you show me the paper
interrupted the listener yes I could but
there's another odd thing about it that
same afternoon and I took it out of my
locker I know for certain it was the
same bit for I made a finger mark on it
and no single trace of writing of any
kind was there on it I kept it as I said
and since that time I tried various
experiments to see whether sympathetic
ink had been used but absolutely without
result so much for that after about half
an hour Sampson looked in again said he
had felt very unwell and told us we
might go
he came rather gingerly to his desk and
gave just one look at the uppermost
paper and I suppose he thought he must
have been dreaming anyhow he asked no
questions that day was a half holiday
and next day Sampson was in school again
much as usual that night the third and
last incident my story happened
we MacLeod and I slept in a dormitory at
right angles to the main building
Sampson slept in the main building on
the first floor there was a very bright
full moon at an hour which I can't tell
exactly but sometime between 1 & 2 I was
woken up by somebody shaking me it was
McLeod in a nice state of mind he seemed
to be in [ __ ] he said come there's a
burglar getting in through Samson's
window as soon as I could speak I said
well why not call out and wake everybody
up no no he said I'm not sure who it is
don't make a row come and look
naturally I came and looked and
naturally there was no one there I was
cross enough and should have called
McCloud plenty of names only
I couldn't tell why it seemed to me that
there was something wrong something that
made me very glad I wasn't alone to face
it we were still at the window looking
out and as soon as I could I asked him
what he had heard or seen I didn't hear
anything at all he said but about five
minutes before I woke you I found myself
looking out of this window here and
there was a man sitting or kneeling on
Sampson's windowsill and looking in and
I thought he was beckoning what sort of
man McCloud wriggled I don't know he
said but I can tell you one thing he was
beastly thin and he looked as if he was
wet all over and he said looking round
and whispering as if he hardly liked to
hear himself I'm not at all sure that he
was alive we went on talking in whispers
some time longer and eventually crept
back to bed no one else in the room woke
or stirred the whole time I believe we
did sleep a bit afterwards but we were
very cheap next day and next day mr.
Sampson was gone not to be found and I
believe no trace of him has ever come to
light sense in thinking it over one of
the oddest things about it all has
seemed to me to be the fact that neither
McCloud nor I ever mentioned what we had
seen to any third person whatsoever of
course no questions were asked on the
subjects and if they had been I'm
inclined to believe that we could not
have made any answer we seemed unable to
speak about it that is my story said the
narrator the only approach to a ghost
story connected with a school that I
know but still I think an approach to
such a thing the sequel to this may
perhaps be reckoned highly conventional
but a sequel there is and so it must be
produced there had been more than one
listener to the story and in the latter
part of that same year or of the next
one such listener was staying at a
country house in Ireland one evening his
host was turning over a drawer full of
odds and ends in the smoking room
suddenly he put his hand upon a little
box now he said you know about old
things tell me what that is
my friend opened the little box and
found in it a thin gold chain with an
object attached to it he glanced at the
object and then took off his spectacles
to examine it morning
what's the history of this he asked odd
enough was the answer you know of the
you thicket in the shrubbery well a year
or two back we were cleaning out the old
well that used to be in the clearing
here and what do you suppose we found is
it possible that you found a body said
the visitor with an odd feeling of
nervousness we did that but what's more
in every sense of the word we found -
good heavens - was there anything to
show how they got there was this thing
found with them it was amongst the rags
of the clothes that were on one of the
bodies a bad business whatever the story
of it may have been one body had the
arms tight round the other they must
have been there 30 years or more long
enough before we came to this place you
may judge we filled the well up fast
enough do you make anything of what's
cut on that gold chain you have there I
think I can said my friend holding it to
the light but he read it without much
difficulty it seems to be GWS 24 July
1865
you